With edema our son is okay
Yes, it no, so if you have edema. Let's say I have swollen legs. Can you go with a son?
It can make it better
But it can irritate it everybody's a little bit different by sweating. You could actually expel some of that water
Theoretically, but sometimes you could actually
It could it can make it worse
So you could try it. I would just be careful
Just be careful with it. I picked up the liquid aloe vera, which has about 40% alcohol pretty intense and taste terrible
I would much rather use an aloe juice by myself with that be better sure give that a try
Yeah, just if you can find a local aloe juice that would be fine. You could also if you have aloe clients
You could you know make your old use out of the aloe plants too